[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله واجواء
من التوتر في ظل مواصله قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اعمال بحث وتمشيط شملت قرى
وبلدات في مناطق متفرقه شماليه الضفه
الغربيه
ننتقل الى ام درمان ومعارك وصفت بالاعنف
منذ اندلاع القتال في السودان الجيش يقصف
بالمسيرات والمدفعيه مواقع للدعم السريع
في الخرطوم وام درمان
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تجدد الهجمات الاوكرانيه بالمسيرات في
العمق الروسي روسيا تعلن تعرض اربع مناطق
منها موسكو للاستهداف زيلينسكي يحصل على
تعهدات بتسليم مقاتلات اف 16 خلال اشهر
الدنمارك تؤكد تسليم الدفعه الاولى بحلول
العام الجديد وهولندا تشدد على ضروره
استيفاء كييف شروط تسلم المقاتلات
ازمه النيجر بين حراك الداخل وضغوط
الخارجواز يختتم زيارته ويؤكد استمرار
التواصل مع قاده الانقلاب المجلس العسكري
يرفض مطالب المجموعه ويعلن فتره انتقاليه
لتحديد معالم النظام الجديد وفي العاصمه
النياميه حشد للمتطوعين للقتال ومظاهرات
دعما للانقلاب
وتيره المعارك تتصاعد في السودان مع تكثيف
الجيش استهدافه لمواقع الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم والامم المتحده تحذر من تنام
العنف كلوفان وتدعو لحمايه المدنيين وسط
حركه نزوح واعمال نهب واسعه في مدينه
الفوله
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مشهد الازمه في النيجر بعد
زياره وفد من جماعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس واعنان قاده الانقلاب عن
فتره انتقاليه لن تتجاوز مدتها ثلاث سنوات
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما
هي مسارات الازمه بعد زياره وفد اكواس
واعلان فتره انتقاليه الاجابات جاءت على
النحو التالي 32% اعتبروا ان الازمه تتجه
نحو حل الدبلوماسي
31% يعتقدون ان احتمال تدخل العسكري لا
يزال قائما بينما قال
37% ان الازمه ستستمر في حاله جمود دون حل
واضح
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مظاهرات في السويداء السوريه احتجاجا على
تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه
[موسيقى]
نبدا من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا فدخول
المقاتلات وتحديدا اف 16 الى ساحه المعركه
قد يكون اقرب مما كان متصورا سابقا رئيسه
وزراء الدنمارك ميتا فريدريكسون ابلغت
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ان الدفعه الاولى
من تلك المقاتلات قد تكونوا في حوزه
اوكرانيا مع بدايه العام المقبل
اعلنا اليوم اننا سنتبرع ب 19 مقاتله من
طراز اف 16 بالشركه معهنلندا ونحن بذلك
نكون اول الدول التي ستقوم بهذه الخطوه
للوفاء بالتزامنا الثابت بتقديم مقاتلات
غربيه لكم ونامل ان يتبعنا الاخرون ان
قدره اوكرانيا على تامين اجوائها امر مهم
جدا نامل ونؤمن بان المقاتلات الدنماركيه
ستساعدكم في الدفاع عن سمائكم
تبدو زياره الى الدنمارك وهولندا المرتبطه
بالحصول على طائرات اف 16 اذانا بمرحله
مقبله في الحرب وتاتي في وقت لم تخلو فيها
اجواء المعركه من اخبار هجمات المسيارات
في الجو في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
المسيرات في قلب المعركه واستخدامها يتم
بوتيره متسارعه رغم محدوديه ما تحققه على
الارض الا ان الاثر المعنوي لها يكمن في
قدرته على الاختراق والوصول اربع مناطق
منفصله في روسيا تعرضت لهجمه بطائره بدون
طيار شملت كورس كوارستوف وبالقرود على
الحدود مع اوكرانيا لكن العاصمه موسكو لم
تسلم ايضا في كورسكا غربيه روسيا تحطمت
مسيره على سقف محطه قطار بينما لم تقع
اصابه في هجوم روستوف اما في مقاطعه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان المضادات الجويه تمكنت
من احباط هجوم بثلاث مسيرات دون اضرار كما
تحدثت عن صد الطائره مسيره اوكرانيا في
منطقه موسكو وتحطمها في منطقه غير ماهوله
ما اوقف لفتره وجيزه رحلت الجويه الى
مطاري
بالعاصمه اكثر من 140 هجوما جويا بدون
طيار هذا العام وفقا للتقارير والسائل
الاعلام الروسيه حدثت في روسيا والاراضي
التي تسيطر عليها في اوكرانيا تركزت هذه
الهجمات في بريانسكو بالقرود بالقرب من
الحدود الغربيه لروسيا وكذلك في شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا والعاصمه موسكو
كان اخترها اتهام روسيا واوكرانيا بمحاوله
اغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في هجوم
بمسيره استهدف الكريم
لفت ايضا استخدام المسيرات في استهداف
المنشاه النفطيه والمطارات والبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه اما من حيث طبيعتها فبرز
استخدام كياب الطائرات بدون طيار من نوع
يوجي 22 ويبلغ مداها نحو 800 كم فضلا عن
طائرات بمقدار التركيه باثنين تلك معركه
الجوي بالمسيره تساعدها كياف لكن عينها
ايضا على الطائرات المقاتله
قائد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اكد ان
العمل بدا لتجهيز مدارج الطائرات كي تكون
صالحه للاستخدام ومناسبه لاستقبال مقاتلات
يتعلق الامر بمقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه
كاولويه قصوى لكن السعي قائم ايضا للحصول
على الطائره السويديه
ثم المقاتل البريطاني تايفون تليها مقاتله
رافال الفرنسيه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني قال
ان الطيارين الاوكرانيين بداوا التدريب
على تشغيل الطائرات وقد يستغرق ذلك سته
اشهر على الاقل ولهذا بدا زيلينسكي متحفزا
هنا في قاعده للقوات الجويه الهولنديه مع
رئيس الوزراء الهولندي
روتاكد التزامه هولندا والدنمارك بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتله اف 16 بمجرد استيفاء
كياب للشروط وفي الدنمارك التي وصلها وفي
قاعده الجويه وفي صوره محمله برسائل جلس
الرئيس الاوكراني على مقاعد الطائره
مقاتله من طراز اف 16 الى جانب رئيسه
الوزراء الدنماركيه
التي اعلنت التبرع لاوكرانيا بتسعه عشره
مقاتله من هذا النوع
رهانو كييف وفق تصريحات مسؤوليها على احد
ابرز مفاتيح التفوق وقلب معادله المعارك
المقاتلات لكن بمقابلها حسابات وعوامل
تعود عليها روسيا للتفوق على ارض المعركه
ينضم الينا من لهاي المقدم باتريك بولدر
الضابط السابق في القوات الجويه الهولنديه
والخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي بمركز لاهاي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن موسكو العقيده
فلاديمير ايرينسيان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي والضابط السابقه في البحريه
الروسيه ابدا معك سيد باتريك تبدو
اوكرانيا متفائله بان استلام طائرات اف 16
سيغير مسار المعركه مسار المعركه هل يتوقف
فقط على استلام هذه الطائرات ام على عددها
ومد الجيل التي تنتمي الي هذه الطائرات
وعوامل اخرى
الان
الاوكرانيون يقاتلون من دون اي سلاح جوي
مؤثر ووصولي الطائرات هذه سيعزز من قدراته
في نفس الوقت نرى ان روسيا لديها وقت موقف
قوي من حيث الدفاعات الجويه داخل اجواء
الاوكرانيه
الاوكرانيون يعملون بان طائرات الاف سته
عشرات تعطيهم المزيد من حريه الحركه
وان تساعدهم على استعاده الاراضي التي
استولت عليها روسيا منهم والاف سته اعشار
بامكانها ان تقدم الدعم والاسناد الارضي
للقوات
البريه ومن اجل تحرير الاوكرانين لاراضيهم
وايضا ممكن ان تعرقل خطوط الامدادات
الروسيه
وتعرقل الوصول الوقود
والذخيره الى القوات الروسيه في الخطوط
الاماميه مما قد يؤدي الى اضعافها ومن ثم
التغلب عليها في الميدان عقيده ان استمعت
الى ما قاله السيد
باتريك الن تغير او يغير استلام هذه
الطائرات
اوكرانيا من تكتيكات روسيا في هذه الحرب
الممتده منذ اكثر من عام ونصف
ان القوات الروسيه تنتظر الاف 16 بفارغ
الصبر حتى تقوم بتدمير خرافه جديده عن
القدرات الغربيه دمرنا الخرافات عن
اليبارد بانظمه الدفاع عن الدبابات
وبالمروحيات الروسيه والان ننتظر الافتت
تتعاشر سوف
وبكل سعاده وسهوله
نحطم هذه الخرافات عن المعدات الغربيه سوف
نسقطها بانظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه مثل
بوك وبوك واحد وطور وغيرها اس 4 ومختلف
انظمه الدفاع الجوي ننتظر هذه الطائرات
القتاليه على ارض المعركه ولن تغير من
تفوقنا في الاجواء
التي لدينا بفضل الطائرات والمقاتلات
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
البعض يعتقد ان الجبلين ومختلف
الاسلحه السويديه سواء كانت المسيرات
البحريه ميكولا والان لديهم الويندرويد 16
من النموذج القديم اين سوف يحصل على
الطيارين كيف سيدربوهم كم سيستغرق هذا من
الوقت هذا شيء مهم ايضا لان تحضير هؤلاء
طائرات ستحتاج الى اوقات طويله تماما مثل
تحضير سائقين المسيرات سوف يحتاج يعني من
الواضح بانه بات هنالك خارطه طريق واضحه
هنالك تحديد لوقت تسليم هذه الطائرات واين
سيتم تدريب الطيارين وما هي الدول التي
ستعطي اوكرانيا هذه الطائرات الامر لم يعد
خطه مطلقه بل باتت هنالك مواعيد
التوقيت والجدول الزمني واضح ولكن هذا
الجدول الزمني يتغير باستمرار لان
اوكرانيا لا تعتبر كشريك مساوي معهم بل
هناك مفهوم مفهوم الخداع والغش غش الشركاء
الاصغر الذين لا يعتبروا انهم بشرا انظروا
الى تكتيك البنتاجون التي تعتمد على القصف
بالطائرات ثم الهجوم بالقوات البريه الان
نرى ان القوات البريه الاوكرانيه تهاجم
المواقع الروسيه دون اي دعم جوي بل حولوهم
للحم للفرامات وهؤلاء ضحايا الهجمات
المضاده وهذا ما يحدث الان انهم يقوم
بخداع
الاوكرانيين ليقوموا بتصعيد جديد حتى يدمر
الشعب الاوكراني
والكثيرين من الاوكرانيين سوف يصبحوا
اتباع لي بول وهذا هو ما تريد ان تقضيه
ساعود اليك ولكن دعني اسمع من المقدم
باتريك سيد باتريك يعني استمعت الى ما
قاله العقيده فلاديمير وكان روسيا تتاقلم
مع الحسابات الجديده واشار الى الاسلحه
السابقه التي تم تزويد اوكرانيا بها اذا
ما قارنا القدرات الجويه والطائرات التي
تمتلكها روسيا حاليا مع الاف سته عشر اي
استنتاجات نخرج بها وما هي اعداد الطائرات
التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا لكي تحدث فرقا على
الارض
16 لديها قدرات اكثر مما لديه لدى
الاوكرانيين من طائرات حاليا من ميغوسو
اذا هذا قد يساعد
الاوكرانيين اولا على استعاده الاراضي
التي استولى عليها روس بشكل غير قانوني في
هذه الحرب غير المبرره الان الدنمارك
تتحدث عن 19 طائره هولندا تتحدث عن حوالي
اربعين طائره ثم ان نرويطيون والبلجيكيون
سيحضون حظهم هنا نرى ان الروس طائراتهم
فعاله لكن الاوكرانيين ايضا سعوا الى
تعزيز الدفاعاتهم
الجويه هذه الطائرات ستساعد
الاوكرانيين على طرد القوات الروسيه
واستعاده الاوكرانيين لاراضيهم العقيده
الرو حدث عن كثير من الامور الاخرى هذه
كلها مجرد دعايه سنرى الواقع على الارض
راينا العدوان الروسي اوقف عند حده في
سبتمبر ونوفمبر تم ارجاعهم الى الوراء ومع
طائرات سته عشر
سيحصل الاوكرانيين على المزيد من الثقه
والزخم لتعزيز
هجومهم لاستعاده ارضهم لضمان ان دوله
اوكرانيا ذات السياده تعود مره اخرى دوله
حره حديثه اشرت الى الدول التي اعلنت عن
عدد من الطائرات التي تريد ان تزود
اوكرانيا بها ولكن التقديرات العسكريه
للمحللين العسكريين تقول بان اوكرانيا
بحاجه الى 100 طائره على الاقل لتحدث فرقا
هل الغرب مستعد لتزويد اوكرانيا بهذا
العدد
الاربعين طائره من هولندا وتسعه عشر من
الدنمارك ووصلت هي تفوق نصف العدد المطلوب
اذا نحن نقترب من حوالي 60 طائره
ولدينا البلجيكيون والنرويجيون
لديهم سته عشر السويديون قد يقدمون طائره
صابر
واذا لو هذا التحالف استمر في تقديم هذه
المساعدات فان المعاناه الانسانيه
للشعب الاوكراني
ستساعد الجميع
لمساعده بلده اعتقد انه بسهوله يمكن ان
نصل الى عدد او رقم 100 طائره اكيد
فلاديمير قللت من شان هذه الاسلحه التي
تزود بها اوكرانيا ولكن ذلك ادى الى
استمرار ما تسميه روسيا بعمليه خاصه
لاكثر من عام ونصف
مكسيما
اكبر عدد ممكن من المقاتلات التي قد تحصل
عليه
اوكرانيا هو عدد قليل ضئيل جدا في الواقع
هذه الارقام التي تعلن هي مجرد
وسائل الغش والاغراءات انهم يقوموا
بمساعده اوكرانيا كما نرى بتقديم فرق
صغيره من مضادات الجويه او بعض الدبابات
الالمانيه التي لا تعتبر من الموديلات
الحديثه
السته التي تشتعل الان من
معداتنا المضاده للدبابات اما بالنسبه
للطائرات المتعدده الوظائف مثل اف 16 هذه
طائرات قديمه عن ذلك ليس لدى اوكرانيا او
الطيارين حتى وان استاجروا الطيارين
الاجانب فسوف يستخدم الوسائل القديمه
لانهم ليس لديهم خبرات حديثه ولم يحاربوا
حقيقه وطيارين لديهم خبرات غنيه في القيام
بعمليات عسكريه في سوريا وقد اثبتوا
جدارتهم اثناء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الفكره سيد فلاديمير ايرانيسيان الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابط السابق في
البحريه الروسيه شكرا لك كما نشكر المقدم
باتريك بولدر الضابط السابق في القوات
الجويه الهولنديه والخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي بمركز لهاي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
اختتم وفدو اكواس زيارته الى اليامي بنبره
تفاؤل حذر عن تشكل ملامح طريق قد يمهد لحل
الازمه وهو ما يطرح اسئله عن تراجع خيار
التدخل العسكري الذي اعلنت المجموعه قبل
يومين انها اقرت خطته في مقابل ذلك يبدو
القاده العسكريون في نياميه متمسكين
بموقفهم المعلن برفض عوده الرئيس المحتجز
الى السلطه
لا يمل الوسطاء من التقاطر على نيامه فما
يكاد فريق يرحل حتى يخلفه اخر قاده
الاكواس بقياده رئيس نيجيريا السابق عبد
السلام ابو بكر قابل الرئيس المحتشز وقاده
الانقلاب لكنهم غادروا البلاد دون نتائج
ملموسه قالوا ان اللقاءات يمكن ان تشكل
منطلقا لحل الازمه لكن مصادر من وراء
الجدران قالت ان العسكره شيعوهم بعباره
واحده بازو لن يعود
بما ينشغل به اضرابهم عاده بعد كل انقلاب
القوات المسلحه على السلطه ومباركه من
الشعب هو جزء من مساء تهدف الى القضاء على
السياسات الخاطئه والظلم الاداره التي
كانت تمارسها سلطه تدعي الديمقراطيه وهي
منها براء سنرسخ مبادئ حريه التعبير ونحرص
على تمكين الناس من انتخاب قادتهم
البحث عن الشرعيه هو الشاغل اذا
يحرص ساده يامي الجدد على خروج المظاهرات
المناصره لهم مستثمرين النقمه على
المستعمر السابق فرنسا لكنهم يروجون لسيد
جديد اخر هو روسيا كما ينشغلون بشحن
المواطنين بشعارات الدفاع عن الوطن الان
المهدد بالغزو الوشيك
جئنا للتطوع في الخدمه العسكريه وهناك
كثيرون من اطراف البلد تنادوا الى الدعوه
للتجنيد نحن هنا منذ الصباح ونود شكر
رئيسنا على كل ما يقوم به مجموعه الايكواز
كانت قد صرحت بانها حسمت امرها لتدخل
عسكري وشيك
لكن مالي وبوركينا فاسو اللتين سبقتها
النيجر للانقلابات هددتها مرارا بتدخل
دعما لعسكري يامه كذلك
كل هذا تسرع البلاد خطاها الى طريق مجهول
طريق حائر بين مؤيدين لرئيس معزول يملك
حقا دون قوه وجنرالات يملكون القوه لتنفيذ
ما يريدون واقليم مرتبك لا تنقصه دوله
فاشله جديده
ينضم الينا من ابوجع عبد الفتاح موسى مفوض
الشؤون السياسيه والسلم والامن في مجموعه
اكواس سيد عبد الفتاح كيف تقيمون كيف
تقيمون زياره الوفد الى النيجر ما الذي
حققه في هذه السياره
اوكي نعم شكرا جزيلا اولا اعتقد انه حتى
اللحظه
الوفد كان
يفندوا كل
المحاولات من اداره
اكواس فيما يتعلق بالتدخل في ذلك البلد
اذا ما تذكرتم
ان الجرار عبد السلام ابو بكر في محاولات
الاولى لم يتم قبول زيارته هو بقي في
المطار ولم يسمح له بالمغادر هذه المره
فرشه له السجاده الحمراء لينقل موقف
الاكواس الى قاده
الانقلاب وسمح له برؤيه الرئيس المحتز
محمد بازون اذا
من كل الجوانب يمكن ان نقول ان ما حصل
اليوم او امس كان تحولا ايجابيا من وجهه
نظر اقواس مقارنه بما حدث في الماضي سيد
عبد الفتاح موسى ولكن بعد هذه الزياره
مباشره خرج السيده يامي ووضع خارطه الطريق
تتحدث عن فتره انتقاليه من ثلاثه سنوات
ودعوه من اجل حوار لوضع اسس دستور جديد لا
تتجاوز الثلاثين يوما
هذه محاولات تاخير نحن نعتقد في اكواس هذه
محاوله في البدايه في كما يفعل المقامرون
يكشفون عن اوراقهم لكي يراها الطرف الاخر
نحن نرى ان النيجر كان فيها دستور جديد
ظهر الوجود في 2010 وفي 2017 تم اعاده
النظر فيه الدستور الان هو لا يزيد عمره
عن سبع سنوات اذا ماذا حصل في هذه السنوات
القليله لتبرير تعديل جديد للدستور فتره
الانتقال غير مقبوله
للاكواس نحن لن نقبلها ولن ندخل في
بقايضات ومرابحات مع الانقرابين موقف
الاكواس واضح
نطلق صراحه الرئيس بازو ويطلق ويفرج عن
عائلته
وزملائه في الحكومه يجب ان يفرج عنهم
ويعاد الوضع القانوني او الدستوري الى عهد
السابق هذا هو وضعه هذا الوضع الصحيح فتره
الثلاث سنوات لا تعنينا
ولن تغير من تعاملنا مع المجلس الوطني
لحمايه الوطن في النيجر
الاكواس لا تريد محاربه شعب النيجر
الاكواس لديها مشكله مع الطعم الانقلابيه
هم بداوا
بمحاولتهم هذه في المغامره والمغامره ونحن
لا نريد ولا نقبل ذلك نريد للوضع الدستوري
ان يعود الى وضعه الطبيعي بالنسبه الينا و
نقاشاتنا هذه هي الماده الوحيده على جدول
الاعمال
تهديدنا باستخدام العمل العسكري لم نسحبه
من الطاوله ما زال موجودا واذا ما ادركنا
انهم يتلاعبون معنا
وليسوا جادين في التفاوض ولا يريدون
التفاوض بنيه حسنه لاعاده البلد الى وضعه
الدستوري سوف نستخدم كل الخيارات المتاحه
لنا للاكواس للتعامل مع الوضع في النيجر
سيد عبد الفتاح التفاوض يحتاج تنازلات من
قبل الطرفين هل موقفكم من اطلاق سراح بزوم
والمرحله الانتقاليه هو موقف نهائي ام
قابل للتفاوض قابل للتعديل هل يمكن ان
ترضي الاكواس او ان ترضى الاكواس بسنه على
سبيل المثال كمرحله انتقاليه
اسمعوا ما اقول الفتره يمكن ان تقرر عندما
تقرر السلطات الاكواس ان هناك فتره معقوله
الاكواس يمكن ان تدرس وتتفاوض نحن
لدينا في الماضي وعلى مدى ثلاث سنوات مع
انت انقلابات سابقه عندما استمرنا في
التقايض والمساومه
وهذه البلدان ما زالت تفكر في تمديد
الفترات الانتقاليه التي سبق وان اتفقوا
عليهم على الاكواس هذه المره سنرفض رفضا
باتا ولم نبدا جوله جديده من المفاوضات
التي لا نهايه لها مع المجلس الوطني
لحمايه الوطن في النيجر نحن نريد فتره
انتقاليه قصيره جدا ليس كما كان يحصل
استئناف الوضع الدستوري واستعادته فورا
لكن لم تستخدم كل ادواتها الضاغطه في
النيجر ويمكننا ان تفعل ذلك وعلى المجلس
الوطني
لحماده الوطن ان يفهم اننا صبورون لكن
صبرنا ينفذ وليس له حدود وعليهما نتفاوضوا
بجديه
هذه فتره تتراسل ذوات نقطه لن تقبلها
الاكواس ابدا شكرا لك يا عبد الفتاح مسمى
مفوض الشؤون السياسيه والسلم والامن في
مجموعات اكواس
تنضم الينا من ميامي حول نفس الموضوع
ماريا صالح القياديه في الحركه الوطنيه
لحمايه الوطن سيده ماريا استمعت لما قاله
السيد عبد الفتاح موسى الخيار العسكري لا
يزال على الطاوله ولم تتخلى اكواس عنه
للبدء اقول بانني سمعت فيما قاله بان
الكواستود حمايه الشعب النيجيري
سيده ماريا يصل الصوت بشكل واضح
اولا اود سمعت
انه يقول بان لك وسيدو حمايه الشعب
النيجيري وهنا اقول
هذا خطا وكلام غير صحيح اطلاقا لانه لو ان
اخوه يريد حمايه الشعب النيجيري
فرض عقوبات قاسيه على الشعب لناخذ مثال
صغير فتن هنا على الحدود
لا ينبغي الحدود
وهناك الكثير نواد الغذائيه والادويه التي
يمكن ان تتلف محجوز على الحدود لا يمكن ان
تدخل البلاد اذا هم لا يهتمون بالشعب
النيجيري وايضا يقول بانه يمكن العوده الى
النظام الدستوري وهذا اي غير صحيح اطلاقا
لان الحركه التي قمنا بها لن تسمح بذلك
ونحن شعبا نيجر لا يسمح بذلك اما مساله
تحرير الرئيس معزوم
نحن مستعدون ذلك على الشطر لا ي البلاد
لان لابد ان يخضع العداله اذ انما الزمل
لابد ان يواجه التهم المطلوقه
نتائج مقام به من اعمال كما انه ليس هم
الذين يحدد لنا فترات او مده فتره
الانتقاليه اسفه الشعب النيجيري هو مستعد
ومستعد لتحمل عقوبات الاكواز واذا حافظوا
على موقفهم هذا ذلك فنحن نحافظ على موقفنا
الشعب النيجيري هو
لا يمكن ان يخاف من العقوبات يفرضها طيب
اذا كانت العقوبات وكما ذكرتي في البدايه
تؤرق الشعب النيجيري والسلطات الانقلابيه
هي المسؤوله عن هذا الشعب لماذا لا تتجاوب
مع مطالب الاكواز او على الاقل تحاول ان
تصل الى صيغ
ه مشتركه معهم الى نقطه التقاء
جانب الوحيد هو هنا ان الرئيس قال نعم قال
باننا مستعدون مستعدون
للمفاوضات ولكن
لاكواس فرضوا عقوبات شاده شديده على الشعب
النيجيري وهذا امر لا يمكن الحقيقه ان
نقبله لا يمكن قبوله اطلاقا
هذا هذا هو ان الحرق الشعبيه لدعم
تتدخل لدعم الشعب
وهم يقولون انهم يريدون حمايه الشعب كله
هذا غير صحيح هم ليس لديهم اي حب او تعاطف
مع الشعب النيجيري والدليل على ذلك فرض
العقوبات القاسيه على الشعب حتى يصلها
مستوى التهديد بالتدخل العسكري
هذه عقوبات غير قانونيه مفروضه على بلادنا
شكرا لك من اليمين ماريا صالح القياديه في
الحركه الوطنيه لحمايه الوطن
[موسيقى]
تتصاعد حده القتال في شهره الخامس ولا
يبدو ان طريق الحل السياسي في السودان
سالك حتى الان على الاقل الخرطوم لا تزال
في قلب الاحداث مع تبادل الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع قصفا مدفعيا وصف
بالعنيف في مناطق الشرق ووسط وجنوب
العاصمه وافاد شهود ان الجيش السوداني
يستهدف عددا من مواقع الدعم السريع
بمسيارات وسجلت مصادر محليه للجزيره فمع
عدوي انفجارات عنيفه ومتواليه في المدينه
الرياضيه جنوبيه
وبحسب مصدر في الجيش السوداني فان
المسيرات التابعه له استهدفت مواقع الدعم
السريع باحياء الصحافه والعشراء والشجره
جنوبيه مديده الخرطوم وشهد حي الشجره
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الطرفين في محيط سلاح
الذخيره في اندرمان نفذت طائرات الجيش
طلعات جويه استهدفت مواقع للدعم السريع
ودارت اشتباكات في عدد من احياء المدينه
بالانتقال الى كردفان افاد مراسل الجزيره
ان الجيش ارسل تعزيزات الى ولايه غرب
كردفان لفرض الامن ووقف عمليات النهب في
مدينه الفوله التي شهدت حركه نزوح بينما
توجه التعزيزات عسكريه اخرى لتامين حقود
النفط
كل هذه التطورات لم تحجب الماسي التي
تشهدها بعض مناطق دارفور بولايه جنوب
دارفور لا تزال نيالا تحت وطاه قتال عنيف
مستمر منذ اسبوع وتقول مصادر محليه ان
المناطق الجنوبيه والشماليه من المدينه
تشهد حرب شوارع
ضرابه القتال وانقطاع الاتصالات عن نيالا
دفع السكان للنزوح عنها ووصل النازحون الى
مدينه الضعان في ولايه شرق دارفور التي
تبعد قرابه 300 كيلومتر عن نيالا ونقل
النازحون صوره ماساويه للاوضاع في نيالا
حيث ادى القتال الى مقتل واصابه عشرات
المدنيين وانقطاع شبه كامل للخدمات
الاساسيه من مياه وكهرباء بعثه الامم
المتحده للمساعده الانتقاليه في السودان
ابدت قلقا متزايدا
من مستويات العنف في المناطق السكنيه
بولايتي جنوبي وغرب كردفان ودعت جميع
الجهات العسكريه الى الامتناع عن الاعمال
التي يمكن ان تشعل المزيد من الصراع
[موسيقى]
تواصل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعمال
تمشيطا شملت قرى وبلدات في مناطق متفرقه
شماليه الضفه الغربيه بحثا عن منافذ عمليه
اطلاق النار التي وقعت امس في بلده حواره
وادت الى مقتل اسرائيليين وقال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان منفذ العمليه سيلقى حتفه في وقت اقرب
مما يتوقع اما وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
فقد دانت هجمات من سمتها ميليشيات
المستوطنين وعناصرهم الارهابيه على بلده
حواره والقرى المجاوره
حاله استنفار عامه اعلنها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بحثا عن منفذ عمليه حواره نقاط
تفتيش على الطرقات وعمليات تمشيط ومداهمات
واعتقالات يقول الفلسطينيون ان قوات
الاحتلال شنت حمله اعتقالات وتمشيط ودهم
في قرى عريف وماجما وبيتا واحكمت اغلاق
بلده حواء بين نابلس ورام الله اصابت
قواته الاحتلال مستوطنا بجروح عندما اطلقت
النار على مجموعه من المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين لاعتقادها انهم فلسطينيون
يشير الحادث الى حاله الارتباك التي
يعيشها جيش الاحتلال بسبب تنفيذ
الفلسطينيين مزيدا من العمليات ضد قواته
والمستوطنين خلال الجلسه الاسبوعيه
لحكومته قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان منفذ عمليه حواره
سيلقى حتفه قريبا كما حدث مع من نفذوا
هجمات سابقه يحاول نتنياهو ان يثبت ان
عمليه كالتي وقعت في حواره لن تهز حكومته
لكن سياسه استخدام العنف المفرط للردع
التي تبنتها هذه الحكومه التي تصنف بانها
الاكثر تشددا في تاريخ اسرائيل لم تمنع
الفلسطينيين من تنفيذ عملياتهم
في المقابل شجعت المستوطنين على ممارسه
مزيد من العنف بحق الفلسطينيين بعد عمليه
حواره تحدثت مصادر فلسطينيه عن هجمات
مستوطنين في عدد من المواقع بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله زادت جراه هؤلاء
المستوطنين لان حكومه نتنياهو الحاليه هي
الاقرب اليهم وفيها من يمثلهم بعد عمليه
سابقه بحواره في فبراير الماضي دعا وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي الى محو بلده حواره من
الخريطه نفذ المستوطنون حينها هجمات ضد
الفلسطينيين في المنطقه واحرقوا سياراتهم
الان وبعد هجوم حواره تدين الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه هجمات من سمتها ميليشيات
المستوطنين وعناصرهم الارهابيه على بلده
حواره والقرى المجاوره وتقول انها تنظر
بخطوره بالغه لعوده الشعار محو حواره
وتعتبره تحديدا على ارتكاب مجازر اباده
بحق الفلسطينيين
تحذر السلطه الفلسطينيه مما اصبح عنفا
ممنهجا يرتكبه المستوطنون فما كان في
السابق اعمال عنف متفرقه ومعزوله ينفذها
المستوطنون بدا يتحول تدريجيا الى عنف
منظم
احرق فلسطينيون سياره مستوطن اسرائيلي دخل
الى قريه ترمس عيا شمال رام الله وقالت
المصادر الفلسطينيه ان السياره اثارت
شبهات بحدوث اعتداء جديد للمستوطنين على
القريه وقال متحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال ان
قوات الاحتلال وصلت الى المكان لتخليص
الاسرائيلي الذي دخل بسيارته للقريه
وتشتبه بانه اصيب خلال هذه الحادثه
اعلنت منصه ما تصدقش المصريه ان السلطات
في مصر اطلقت صراحه كريم اسعد عضو فريق
تحرير المنصه وانه عاد الى منزله بعد
يومين من اعتقاله وكانت المنصه وقد افادت
بتعرض الصحفي كريم اسعد للاعتقال من قبل
مسلحين بملابس مدنيه وبانهم لم يسالوا سوى
عن تغطيه المنصه لقضيه ضبط السلطات
الزنبيه طائره خاصه اتيه من القاهره محمله
باموال ومعادن واسلحه وكانت نقابه
الصحفيين المصريين قد طالبت السلطات
الامنيه بالكشف عن مكان احتجاز الصحفي
كريم اسعد واطلاق سراحه والافراج عن جميع
الصحفيين المحتجزين في مصر الذي وصل عددهم
الى اربعه وعشرين بينهم تسعه نقابيين
وقالت ان عوده احتجاز الصحفيين تثير
تساؤلات بشان الجهود المبذوله لاغلاق ملف
الحبس الاحتياطي في قضايا
قال عبد الملك العجري عضو الوفد التفاوضي
لجماعه انصار الله الحوثي ان هناك ترتيبات
لجوله مفاوضات مقبله بشان الوضع في اليمن
واكد العجل في منشور على منصه اكس سعيا
وفدها الذي وصل الى العاصمه العمانيه مسقط
ان تكون جوله المفاوضات المنتظره حاسمه في
وضع حد للمعاناه الانسانيه للشعب اليمني
لان استمرارها هو استمرار للحرب بشكل اكثر
فتكا واشد وطئه بحسب تعبيره
في سوريا شهدت مدن وبلدات عده في محافظه
السويداء جنوبي البلاد اضرابا عاما واغلاق
طرق واحتجاجا على تردي الاوضاع المعيشيه
وذكرت مصادر محليه ان عده مظاهرات خرجت
وسط مدينه السويداء وفي عدد من القرى
والبلدات طالبت بالحريه والكرامه ورحيل
رموز النظام كما شهدت محافظه درع المجاوره
مظاهرات مماثله
[تصفيق]
التوتر في محافظه السويداء ياخذ منحا
تصعيديا فالاحتجاجات التي بدات بالمطالبه
بتحسين الظروف المعيشيه انتهت الى
المطالبه برحيل بشار الاسد
[موسيقى]
كما اتسعت رقعه التظاهرات لتشمل ثلاثين
نقطه في مدن وبلدات المحافظه حسب مواقع
اعلاميه محليه
بيان شيخ الطائفه الدرزيه حكمه الهجري
الذي تناقلته مواقع محليه عبر عن ما وصف
بالشرخ الكبير بين سكان السويداء وقياده
النظام السوري فقاده النظام الغرباء بحسب
تعبير البيان يتضرعون بحرب كونيه ضدهم
بينما النظام هو من يتحمل المسؤوليه عن
تدمير الاقتصاد وتجويع الناس
ارتفاع اسعار الوقود في مناطق سيطره
النظام السوري كان الشراره التي اشعلت
الاحتجاجات في السويداء لكن الوضع المتوتر
بين النظام وابناء المحافظه على خلفيه
الاتهامات للنظام بالفساد والتجويع
المقصود للسكان والاعتقالات التي تطال
شباب المدينه بين الحين والاخر رفعت بسرعه
وتيره الاحتجاجات وحده المطالب
الذي وافقت عليه جميع الاطراف من اجل
الانتقال السلمي للسلطه
[تصفيق]
اما في درع المجاوره فعادت المظاهرات
المناهضه للنظام الى مدن رئيسيه رغم تجديد
النظام السوري قبضته الامنيه على المحافظه
بعد سيطرته عليها عام 2018
وامام الجامع العمري الذي شهد بدايه
انطلاق الثوره السوريه عام 2011 رفع
المتظاهرون رايه الثوره رغم ما يعنيه ذلك
من استفزاز كبير لافرع النظام الامنيه
صهيب الخلف الجزيره ادلب
نستكمل بحث موضوع الاضراب العام الذي يشل
محافظه السويداء جنوبي سوريا احتجاجا على
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه المتراديه واخفاق
السلطات في ايجاد حلول محافظه السويداء
التي يبعد مركزها 100 كيلومترات جنوب
العاصمه دمشق يسكنها نحو 770 الف نسمه
ينتمي معظمهم لطائفه الموحدين الدروز مع
وجود اقليه مسيحيه تقع السويداء ضمن مناطق
سيطره النظام السوري لكنها ظلت تشكو ما
تقول انه تهميش اقتصادي وانفلات امني وشل
للحياه المدنيه والقانونيه
لابنائها شهدت المحافظه خلال الاعوام
الاخيره احتجاجات متكرره على تفاقم الازمه
المعيشيه اما الاحتجاجات الحاليه فقط
فجرها ارتفاع اسعار الوقود بعد رفع
الحكومه الدعم عنها في وقت خسرت الليره
السوريه اكثر من 99% من قيمتها وقد تزمنت
تلك الترتيبات مع قرارات حكوميه برفع
رواتب موظفي القطاع الحكومي ورفع الحد
الادنى للاجور للقطاع الخاص لكن هذه
القرارات وفقا لخبراء لم تفلح في تطويق
الازمه
ليست هذه حاله سويداء فقط في مناطق سيطره
النظام السوري تشهد في عمومها واقعا
معيشيا وخدميا هو الاسوا منذ اندلاع
الصراع في البلاد قبل نحو اثنين عشر عاما
معدل التضخم ارتفع في تلك المناطق الى
مستويات غير مسبوقه في حين انخفضت القوه
الشرائيه لسكانها بشكل حاد يعود ذلك في
الجانب منه الى العقوبات التي يفرضها
المجتمع الدولي منذ اكثر من عقد على
النظام بسبب العنف الذي مارسه على
المطالبين بالتغيير
لكن بقيه المناطق السوريه لا تبدو من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه بافضل حال فاغلبيه
السوريين اليوم يعيشون تحت خط الفقر بحسب
تقديرات الامم المتحده
التقديرات ذاتها تشير الى ان اكثر من 12
مليونا من السوريين يعانون من انعدام
الامن الغذائي
لمتابعه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من مدينه
اعزاز بريف حلب خير العبود استاذ الاقتصاد
وعضو نقابه الاقتصاديين السوريين اهلا بك
معنا الا يعتبر ما تشهده سوريا بشكل عام
نتاج طبيعي لسنوات من العقوبات والحصار
المفروض عليها ولسنوات من عدم الاستقرار
حياكم الله الله يمسيكم بالخير جميعا
حقيقه
السوريه هي في واقع مدمر واقع اقتصادي
منتهي قطاعات اقتصاديه متدهوره تضخم هائل
حيث بلغت تضخم من 2011 الى 2023 بحدود 30
الف بالميه
زادت الرواتب بحدود الالف ومئتين بالميه
ففرق كبير شاسع يعني ما بين نسبه التضخم
التي بلغت 30 الف بالميه
فنحن امام كارثه حقيقه الرواتب بهذه
الحاله هيا انخفضت بشكل
رهيب يعني
بحدود
الثلاثين بالثلاثين مره يعني
بالتالي
قطاعات الاقتصاديه كلها مدمره تقريبا
الزراعه لا تعمل الصناعه لا تعمل هناك
فساد حكومي هناك فساد تجاري هناك شبكه من
المحتكرين
المرتبطين بالنظام هم يتحكمون بجلب السلع
والخدمات للناس وبالتالي يتحكمون حتى في
الاسعار
النظام اعتمد منذ بدايه الحرب على الشعب
السوري
النظام التمويل بالعجز يعني هو ما عنده
موارد حقيقه ما ضل عنده موارد ما ضل عندي
الدوله السوريه موارد غالبيه انتهت او
دمرت نتيجه الحرب على الشعب السوري
وبالتالي هو اعتمد سياسه التمويل بالعجز
الامر الاخر تمويل الميليشيات اللي
استجلبها من دول مختلفه كذلك هذه تحتاج
نفقات كبيره وتكاليف باهظه كل ا حملها على
الشعب السوري
يعني ما نشهده في السويداء وفي درع
السويداء كانت قد خرجت اكثر من مره تطالب
بتحسين الاوضاع المعيشيه ما امكانيه ان
يتوسع الى محافظات اخرى
انا اتوقع غالب الشعب السوري في مناطق
النظام ستقوم على هذا النظام لانه ما بقى
امام حل يعني هن وصلوا لطريق مسدود النظام
مهما رفع الرواتب لن يجدي نفعا حتى اذا
رفع الف بالميه لماذا ما راح يجدي نفعل
لانه هي عباره عن
اصدار كتله نقديه جديده وبالتالي تضخم
جديد وبالتالي ارتفاع اسعار جديد وبالتالي
لا يستفيد اي موظف او اي
مقتني للراتب اي فائده هكذا اتوقع سيد
خيره وانا اتوقع كمان بعد زياده الرواتب
الاخيره نعم
اتوقع بعد زياده الرواتب الاخيره ميه
بالميه راح يزيد التضخم وراح يوصل سعر
الدولار بحدود 25 الف ليره سوري بالفتره
القريبه يعني خلال شهر او شهرين بالاكثر
على متى تستندون في توقعاتكم هذه ولا
يعتبر التضخم يعني مشكله عالميه اليوم حتى
الدول الغربيه تعاني منه
لا لا بالنسبه للنظام النظام ليس لديه
موارد ولا حتى حاصلات ضرائب ولا غيره
وبالتالي هو دائما يعتمد اسلوب زياده
الكتله النقديه في تمويل اي زياده في
الرواتب او تمويل نفقات الدوله وبالتالي
دائما في عنا كميات هائله من القطع من
النقد عم تنزل على السوق الجديد وبالتالي
عم يصير تضخم اجباري يعني كميات هائله من
النقد تطارد كميات قليله من السلع
والخدمات ما المخرج سيده خير على المستوى
الاقتصادي في ظل الظرف السياسيه التي
تعيشه سوريا
في الحاله الراهنه ما في اي مخرج ما في
الا مثلا يصير تغير سياسي او غيره
وتباشر مثلا استثمارات جيده وتدخل الى
الداخل السوري وبالتالي تامل فرص عمل
يتامل مواد في الاسواق لانه نحن عنا اسواق
ضعيفه جدا نتيجه الفقر المتقع نتيجه
البطاله بالتالي يعني حتى المستثمرين اللي
بدهم يدخلوا للداخل السوري الجدول
الاقتصاديه عندهم صفر تقريبا او خاسره
بالتالي ما حدا بيتشجع انه يدخل يستثمر في
الاراضي السوريه لانه حاله السوق ضعيفه
جدا
الاقتصاد
وعضو نقابه الاقتصاديين السوريين كنت معنا
من مدينه اعزاز بريف حلب شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
العالم وتقلبات الطقس وتداعيتها ترقب في
مناطق جنوب غرب الولايات المتحده التي
تستعد لاحتمال حدوث فيضانات خطره بسبب
الاعصار هلاري الذي تصاحبه رياح حاتيه
تبلغ سرعتها 140 كيلومتر في الساعه في
كندا يقول مسؤولون ان حرقين هائلين
وسريعين تمدد اندمج خلال الليل غربي
البلاد حيث تهدد النيران مئات المنازل
وتستمر عمليات الاجلاء في مقاطعه كولومبيا
البريطانيه الى جزر الكناري التي تشهد
اكبر حريق للغابات على الاطلاق والخبر
الجيد هو ان رجال الاطفاء اطفاء يحققون
تقدما في مكافحه الحرائق المندلعه منذ
الثلاثاء وفي شمال شرقي اليونان كافح رجال
الاطفاء ثلاثه وخمسين حريقه غابات خلال
الساعات الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه هذه
المشاهد وغيرها تحمل بصمات مابات يعرف
بالطقس المتطرف ما الذي يحدث يقول العلماء
ان ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري التي يسببها
الانسان تجعل ظواهر الطبيعيه الخطره اكثر
تواترا وفتكا كل الامال ان تمر محنه
الالاف وربما عشرات الالاف او اكثر عبر
العالم بسلام ونستوعب جميعا اهميه الحفاظ
على البيئه ختام الحصاد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]